polonais suédois belges italiens dans
les rue de l'orme près de cinquante
visiteurs particuliers représentant de
territoires ruraux et fonctionnaires
européens
pas de tourisme mais une visite de
travail pour s'inspirer des actions en
matière de numérique et de
redynamisation
il ya des choses qui peuvent être
partagées c'est vraiment intéressant de
voir ce qui se fait ailleurs
parce qu'on peut toujours apprendre des
autres et parfois éviter des erreurs qui
ont pu être faites
je crois que tous en europe partout en 1
ces problèmes de ce genre où on en aura
alors il est très intéressant de voir
comment lors manon pratique trouve des
solutions très pratique l'oeuvre depuis
plusieurs années l'homme refuse de céder
au fatalisme de l'exode rural ouverture
de commerces de locaux associatifs
rénovation du centre bourg
la multiplication des actions a permis
de capter de nouveaux habitants près
d'un leurre mois sur 5 n'était pas là il
ya cinq ans comme alain weil séduits par
le cadre et le dynamisme
c'est un plus qui est vraiment
intéressante parce que c'est en plus
nous on a vraiment vu l'évolution comme
ça fait cinq ans qu'on est là vraiment
tout le temps à l'année on a vraiment vu
de changement et le village qui
commencent à agir
[Musique]
pourtant il reste de nombreuses
difficultés pour un village isolé au
coeur du morvan mobilité vieillissement
emploi et pour y faire face l'homme veut
continuer à proposer des solutions
il ya toujours des défis quand on est
dans des petites villes ou des plus
grandes d'ailleurs fait sans fin parce
que le la période que nous traversons
est complexe et la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que quatre ou
cinq générations cohabitent
on a bien tous conscience de la crise de
l'enjeu climatique
on sait qu'on ne connaît pas 50% des
métiers qui existeront dans dix ans donc
partout delorme jusqu'à paris il faut se
mettre en mode innovation en mode
invention des défis pour lesquels la
ville entend bien obtenir des moyens
supplémentaires de l'union européenne
l'homme fait partie des candidats pour
le prochain plan d'action pour des
villages intelligent